bajo estas aguas turquesas frente a la
costa de australia
la gran barrera de coral se vuelve
blanca cada día
con el calentamiento global la
temperatura del agua aumenta
provocando la expulsión de las algas
microscópicas que dan al coral sus
brillantes colores
a las temperaturas en la recife durante
la última semana han estado por encima
de la media de marzo entre medio grado y
dos grados en la mayoría de los lugares
pero hasta cuatro grados en otros esto
significa que el estrés térmico ha
seguido acumulándose en el arrecife
quiero destacar que los corales
blanqueados están estresados pero siguen
vivos si las condiciones se mantienen
moderadas los corales blanqueados pueden
recuperarse de este transformarse tras
los arrecifes de coral son esenciales
para preservar la biodiversidad en ellas
viven todo tipo de peces y otros
animales marinos que se protegen de los
depredadores o se reproducen en ellos se
han organizado vuelos de vigilancia
sobre la gran barrera que se extiende a
lo largo de 2.300 kilómetros la
situación es más grave en el noreste de
australia desde 2015 las autoridades
australianas han invertido miles de
millones de dólares para combatir el
deterioro de la gran barrera de coral
pero esto no ha evitado tres graves
episodios de blanqueo entre 2016 y 2020
si la misión de la onu encuentra
demasiado degradación durante su visita
prevista para junio tendrá que tomar
medidas la gran barrera de coral
patrimonio de la humanidad de la unesco
podría bajar de categoría y entrar en la
lista de lugares en peligro